you know the ET theme song Don't you
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
E.T first met a 19 year old Beyonce in
2000 onset of the Destiny's Child
Independent Women music video I got the
opportunity of writing and producing the
song for the Charlie's Angel soundtrack
and it's a great song it's All About
Women and Independence it's called
Independent Women as a matter of fact
[Music]
and we have our 70s Soul Train outfits
um Tina knows our stylist designed and
I'm really excited about that we're in
front of a green screen they're going to
put the scene in the background after
everything is done which is really
exciting for us Beyonce's other style
inspiration for the video
the OG Angels I'm only 19 and I didn't
see many episodes but I have seen a
couple episodes and the ladies kicked
butt they were they were cool and I
definitely love Farrah Fawcett in the
wings I'm jacking her style
we've had like four number one singles
hopefully this will be the fifth and
I'm just blessed Beyonce got her wish
Independent Women spent 11 weeks at the
billboard number one spot
[Music]
the next year E.T was back on set of
another number one hit which also
spawned a whole new turn
[Music]
bootylicious and I told the girls I was
like I wrote a song called and I was
embarrassed to tell them they were like
well let's go in the studio let's try it
really hot song So bootylicious is about
self-esteem it's about feeling good
about yourself parents don't be afraid
nothing sexual is nothing that your kids
can't listen to say my name say my name
and one thing ET has learned about
Beyonce she's always gonna level up to
any challenge I'm always changing and
trying to always grow and I just want to
do something different because I'm foxy
Patrick and I'm a whole lot of woman
in 2002 E.T was behind the scenes as she
made her feature film debut in Austin
Powers in Gold members
[Music]
yeah I was a little intimidated I know
especially during the table reading I
know when you do movies it was my first
table reading and it was all of these
wonderful legendary actors and I was
really nervous but they made me feel so
at home and so much like a family member
and everybody has been so supportive and
they've given me great words of advice
and it I'm not no longer intimidated I
feel like part of the family but there
was one big drawback in landing the role
I love to eat I love to eat the worst
things cookies Pizza all of that but
foxy has to be fit so I've been eating
salads and all that stuff I don't like
but it's all right it's worth the
sacrifice definitely I couldn't have
found a better first movie to do but
Austin Powers was only the beginning of
Beyonce's Hollywood Evolution hello ET
I'm Beyonce here on the set of the Pink
Panther
there you go by 2008 Beyonce was a
full-fledged actress taking acting
classes and physically transforming
herself for her roles like losing 20
pounds for her part and Dream Girls
[Music]
I wanted to lose all traces of myself so
I didn't recognize myself on screen for
six months I was really hungry but when
we sat down with Beyonce for her last
action movie the 2009 Thriller obsessed
it was clear to us Sasha Fierce was
ready for her close I'll show you crazy
I I'm covered in bruises and I really
did my own stunts I'm a professional
person so I don't really get too gangsta
but I am a businesswoman and I am quite
gangster I should say but back to
Beyonce's musical evolution
in 2003 Beyonce made the Bold decision
to step away from Destiny's Child and go
It Alone
[Music]
Crazy In Love became Beyonce's first
number one single as a solo artist and
featured her future husband Jay-Z the
song Crazy In Love eight weeks at number
one this summer has been wonderful
beyond my expectations the more than I
could ever imagine the song became a
worldwide Smash and E.T was backstage
with Beyonce when the album Dangerously
in Love won five Grammys I still haven't
recovered yeah I'm still like did that
just happen to me I won five I know
that's good I can't believe you five
what are you gonna do with them
um my mother actually has all of my
Awards right now and I have three with
Destiny's Child so that's eight now her
next album D-Day was released in 2006 on
Beyonce's 25th birthday it became her
second consecutive number one hit
and you've accomplished a lot up to 25
you work really hard because you've been
on top so it's hard working to stay on
top it definitely is
it's harder to stay at the top than get
to the top and I can say that
it's so hard but it's it's a challenge
and that's what I love about my life it
was also around that time that Beyonce
and Jay-Z engagement rumors were
everywhere you ready B
let's go get them Jay is saying about
talking about the bling on your finger
what was that is that alluding to
something the key word rumors that's for
you buddy that was that all for me it's
all for you wow sorry so it's just rumor
well that's what the record says but see
I'm not talking about the record now now
I'm talking about you in real life
[Music]
so now what what's next I mean
eventually you gotta take the next step
right
you have 20 minutes right and if you
want to stay in silence we can do that
but oh we're not even going to talk no
yep Beyonce held her ground but you know
I had to ask of course that engagement
did come the following year in 2007 on
April 4th 2008 Beyonce officially became
Mrs Carter
[Music]
Beyonce told us her most poignant
Evolution was becoming a mother even
while still pregnant with Blue Ivy
I am the happiest I've ever been and I
feel the most empowered I don't care if
I won awards or you know I don't care if
I made good money whatever this makes me
feel strong and this makes me proud and
this makes me feel so lucky to be a
woman we are the ish women are
incredible We Run the World
what's the best thing about being a mom
so far it's just I have such a full life
I feel like now I know the reason why I
was born
and when it comes to Super Bowl royalty
look no further than queen bee
starting in 2004 when she belted out the
national anthem
[Music]
rest
in 2013 her headlining Act was so
electrifying the power went out
[Applause]
I was on my side so I'm very very happy
that
well and the power went out after okay
wasn't you were you the power outage did
you oh Lord I don't
know Beyonce returned three years later
to help kick off Coldplay's 2016
halftime show
[Applause]
many said she stole the show
[Applause]
Beyonce now enters 2023 a Bonafide music
and style icon but ET will always
remember her as a low-key girl from
Houston figuring out Fame
I don't like to get my hair done I hate
getting makeup done I take quick showers
not luxurious baths I I don't get
pedicures and mannequins as often as I
should I'm just a very
um
earthy chick
turn the lights out